it feels like whenever I talk to these
ego feminists okay they'll be like
you're just a man and you don't
understand how good you have it and I'm
like have you even tried considering
that's not true have you tried thinking
about the things I experienced and what
it's like to grow up no they don't know
so so I actually had an interesting
conversation once with a very
high-profile feminist where this is what
she told me she said men are so
privileged to get everything handed to
them and they just don't understand how
good they have it and I was like have
you ever looked at like what it was
called sexual marketplace data that
OkCupid released so so okay we kind of
talked about this right right right so
OkCupid released data to track the value
of an individual and I found that value
women a man will never in his life reach
the same societal value as a woman
period dude and that growing up until
about the age of 26 or so women have max
societal value it can't get higher
that's the standard it's so high they're
protected they're they're you know
they're given things and that there are
also limitations because it's not like
you're just sitting on a throne no it
means there's gonna be restrictions like
you can't do this you can't do that for
sure but it's about what not society
values you so do you think that these
people are thinking they actually
finally have the upper hand and they
don't want to lose the like minority
status that they used to have that
allows them to complain and well so so
fight do you know where let me I'll tell
you what I'll tell you what I would I
think with this the point I'll make is
young men are valueless literally
valueless okay they have no skills
they're not particularly strong they're
not big and it takes men a long time to
learn the skills to be valuable to
society and to grow and develop muscle
mass and then it's around 26 or more
when men and women start actually
switching places okay so now men in
their thirties are having an easier time
of things are finding more value in
society and women at that age are going
down for obvious biological reasons
which you can get mad at me all you want
this stuff is is studied and you know
it's like I'm not making this up it's
like some immense right stuff it's like
literally they track attractiveness men
want twenty two-year-old women for
babies so here's what I think happens if
you spend your whole life
at at number one so I'll give you a real
good real world example when I was
growing up all of the low-level jobs for
sixteen year olds it's like 90% women
Starbucks barista is ice cream shop
handlers fast food service the grill
cooks were like you know 30 year old
dudes right and then all of the servers
were young women yeah and so you know
one example have to tell people is I
know somebody who was working a
minimum-wage job at a college with a
degree and his sister was getting 200
bucks at night four hours a night
serving food at a restaurant because and
so here's what happens when I when I
would turn 21 I was in Chicago and I
went all of these different businesses
and every single place told me the same
thing when it comes to entry-level stuff
for like bars bar back and servers we do
not hire men Wow so right up just
straight a straight up and I had one guy
who took pity on me because I lived
about a block away from this place and I
was like you know I was talking I was
like I'm trying to find any work I can
and he was Hawaii he's like you tried up
down the street you tried other places
and I was like bro I was like I went
everywhere and they all told me the same
thing
yeah and it's basically like you can get
a crappy minimum-wage bare minimum trash
job and then although in my age were
like bartenders not all of them but like
a lot of them yeah and they work
baristas they're getting mad tips and I
was broke and the dude was like I'll
tell you what man he's like you come in
two hours for clothes you help the the
barbacks I'll toss you 50 bucks for
those you know those two hours and I was
like oh that's 25 bucks an hour dude and
he was like I got you man and it only
lasted a little bit because they end up
going out of business
okay but anyway here's what happens
these women who don't understand that
like I don't know what you could call
like the glass basement I guess like
it's and this is anecdotal for the most
part of me growing up in Chicago but
here's how I feel that could be wrong
that if you if you're growing up and
society treats you as the most important
thing that's your standard to you that's
normal and so what happens when you get
older and it starts getting worse or
losing that effect all of a sudden you
feel like life's not fair why are wise
why are things getting worse for me
yeah then here's what I think you get
youn up seeing and it's being you end up
seeing dudes who all of a sudden things
are getting better so here's what
happens though mints are complaining
life sucks and these men who are seeing
things get better and better are like
man really things are getting so much
better for me and then you end up
with male feminists who are like I'll
help you not realizing yeah that men
according to this was like not just
OkCupid data but basically societal
value overwhelmingly you know favors
young women for a million reasons I can
see that yeah
younger women and older guys yes so you
made the comparison that chicks tend to
start out on an easy setting and then
with four dudes it gets easier as they
go right like you compared it to me okay
I think yeah that was so interesting me
I was like oh my gosh that is accurate
yeah it's like imagine you're playing a
video game and you can choose a
character that has like faster actually
a racing game you can choose the car
with really high acceleration but low
max speed okay or you could use the car
with high max speed in low acceleration
low acceleration car means you're gonna
you're gonna take longer to get to the
first place and you can't mess up right
but once you finally reach that point
you can keep steady and if you've got
the skill you're gonna remain that place
starting with fast acceleration you can
get the first place really really
quickly but then it becomes harder so I
think we end up seeing a lot of women as
they're getting older and they're
they're you know and I'm not saying it's
a good thing that society does this you
know I think you know equality of
opportunity is is an awesome thing I
think people have the right to pursue
you know happiness and that means women
should be able to be CEOs be whatever
they want to be mm-hmm and the
opportunity to do so not the guarantee
they get it right right but I think
that's one of the things we end up
seeing so now you have naturally when
their whole life is is I think this
explains why they don't wanna be garbage
garbage men they don't want to be
interrupted they don't be drafted they
don't be crawling on in sewers because
it's not about equality it's about
maintaining their position of privilege
and as they like to say to the
privileged what do they say to to
equality looks like oppression so now
that they're finally coming down and
coming to an equal position with how men
have lived they feel like they're being
oppressed yeah
but I'll tell you what if you really
want to talk about being oppressed let's
talk about the combat death gap rose at
98 percent male huh 98 percent no one
talk about no one's talking about
closing very dying 75 percent of
homeless people 98 percent of combat
deaths was at 80 percent of suicides
yeah dude it's so so I'm not saying that
women get ever so who really has the
privilege you know its pros and cons
it's a it's it's it's it's yeah I think
it
impossible not smart of lack and white
nothing is really you know but when you
specially this subject yeah when you
start life in hard mode I mean the odds
are you're gonna get drafted and you're
gonna eat killing war you're gonna write
it's a suicide because life is hard and
imagine better imagine if you're a short
guy or a dumb guy or both yeah and then
it's just like because it's it's called
the greater male greater male
variability hypothesis that men occupy
the more extreme ends of the spectrum
relative to women yeah so there are more
stupid men so you you end up with angry
ugly stupid guys they so that's so it
simply an attraction thing to like women
are more attractive in general and so as
they're younger like people want to
gravitate towards the the attractive
girl at the bar not the guy at the bar
yeah like oh cool the guy but the girl
ooh she's cute I want to go talk to her
whether you're a guy or a girl I think
we can all agree well take a look at how
dating sites work go ahead
men do the messaging young men get
messaged no matter what like it's not
obviously
unattractive women get message less they
still get messaged okay they do have to
do some messaging and then the same is
true for women as they get older but one
of the interesting bits of data that was
I think removed by OkCupid because like
the insult community community latched
on to it was that men men's view of
attractiveness for women was a bell
curve so there's the bottom 20% then
there's the top 60% or than the mid 60s
and then the top 20% women viewed every
minute that the top 20th percentile was
averaged to them so like for men it's a
bell curve
the average woman is they would see as
average there was actually there was
actually super attractive kind of ugly
and average but for women allistic yeah
every single guy was unattractive except
for the cream of the crop top at the top
six foot tall chiseled 5 o'clock shadow
abs making good money that's realistic
but that so I think the issue is that
because women get messaged they
basically open up tinder and they look
at their list of all the messages and
gonna do to do badou oh this guy is it
possible they they overestimate their
own market value I mean everyone
everyone does everyone
I think so
Oh dudes definitely every but no
everybody does everyone thinks that
they're right
well basically yeah it's like I'm I am
the master of my mind and the master I
wrote yourself and everyone everyone is
and if it you know it just so happens
you are right you'll you'll tend towards
success yeah true
yeah yeah so then the people who think
they're right but they're dumb don't
understand that they're dumb they tend
towards failure yeah and that's what
breeds socialism and then they actually
mean that especially when they start
blaming others for that failure eventful
yeah exactly
that's worse so that's where you get
such them so it's not surprising to me
that we're seeing you know I did think
it was interesting that we saw an
overlap between the leftist socialist
types and the woke feminist types but it
makes sense yeah it's people who think
they're deserving other people are
stealing and taking away from the minute
it all overlaps so maybe that's it it's
the women when they're younger they're
getting all this stuff and they're used
to it and they're getting all this
attention yep and being doted upon by
guys all over the place cuz you know
they're getting to choose and then
they're starting to lose it and they're
like whoa whoa I have a perfect example
whoa remember that who's that who's that
Guardian feminist and she wrote like men
are kept calling me horrify say and a
year later she was like men don't cat
called me anymore and I'm sad wait
seriously I'm not even kidding
can you try and look that over to know
I'm pretty sure everybody listening is
like familiar with us she said I'm she
said something she said something like
and I'm upset that society makes me miss
it but it's it's perfect
yes that video is so funny
like oh hey hello yeah that's not cat
enjoy the weather like that's I found it
half of the video was silly found it the
end of hisses whistles and stares we
need to walk the streets of that fear
men rarely can't call me anymore I hate
that our culture makes me miss it she
just got older that's all there is to it
but and I'll be fair to one year older
she's saying I hate that our culture
makes me miss it so it's still criticism
right but she was admitting she misses
it yeah so so I actually have another
theory on this oh I think that one of
the one of the reasons men don't get
catcalled is that what makes a man
valuable is like status skill ability
right yeah men do get catcalled there
was this really funny video where this
guy may you know the 10 hours of walking
through New York as a woman mm-hmm
a guy made one and he was a male model
and he got catcalled by women non-stop I
can I actually have been catcalled a lot
in New York yeah I knew and you a model
did used to model in New York funny
enough it wasn't I mean girls did have
done it but it was mostly gay guys
they're more aggressive and yes you're
go after it's what guys do man but still
I get it ok whatever right but here's
the thing I started I started to realize
something when I started getting cat
cold okay I get called all the time by
the cat you don't know him because
people know who I am and so here's what
I was thinking like who's constantly
going yeah yeah yeah for better or for
worse you can criticize it all day and
night society values women for their
tired child-rearing potential it doesn't
need to be that way we've changed that a
lot but that's just like you know you
know I mean you see them saying that men
are attractive what women find
attractive is confidence skill status
ability yeah how do you see those things
yeah Hakan wearing wearing a sombrero
and binoculars rings well so here's how
I started thinking right over the past
several years I get hollered at all the
time it's not the same it's not only
women it's just like people being like
Oh Tim gosh are you Billy Tim can
anything like and they're like nice to
meet you I recognize that beanie yep and
I start next to him is happening
it doesn't wait up and I have a bunch of
friends you know that I've watched that
happened to them too and I started
thinking like this is not the same it's
definitely not the same because like the
actual like cat calling of women can be
creepy it's uncomfortable but there's
there's a similarity to it that the
status is recognizable people like what
you do or what you are or what you have
what you represent now I can certainly
understand
and if women like Jessica Valenti don't
like the fact that their value was
derived from what they look like whereas
mine would be derived from what people
know about me but it's also true that
women have that same privilege as well
that you can be a beautiful and famous
skilled talented whatever like think
about like a famous female gymnast not
only are people gonna be like whoa she's
so attractive they're also gonna be
alike oh man you're so and so yeah so I
think you know men probably don't
understand catcalling
because you can't see status you can't
see confidence but there are some men
who do certainly you've experienced it
yeah but yeah I don't know are we do we
do we make our point I guess should we
should we jump over superjet what is the
point the point the point is basically
that when push comes here so let me wrap
that up actually because yeah we took
this one for like 40 minutes man when
push comes to shove when chaos hits the
when it went you know went cast hits the
fan I was at different works yes he
would say we're family I like that when
chaos hits the fan
all of a sudden now we fall back to the
1950s the men need to go to war the men
you take the risks interestingly though
I know there's gonna be a lot of angry
feminists but a lot of health care
professionals are female yeah a huge
majority right thing like 95 percent and
you know what was interesting to me was
that men tend to make more in nursing
anyway cuz they asked no because they
work as an anesthesiologist in which
they make more money and you end up
working with a machine not a person so
so after everything I've just said there
was one thing I was absolutely saving
for the end of this while I agree with
her to an extent that's gonna send us
back to the 50s the frontline battle
right now is being led by women it's a
pandemic people in hospitals health care
professional help the health care
industry is dominated by women dude yeah
I want I would shout out my coworkers
because they are wearing the masks
they're exactly's are getting that red
thing on the top it's nonsense they're
working their butts off yeah so so I
agree with her to a certain degree but I
think it's important to point that out
this is a battle that can't be won with
with with guns and brawn but in this
fight you do have a lot of women on the
front line taking that risk
yeah and that to me is like actually a
good sign of progress and all that stuff
so as much as I'm sure there's a bunch
of feminists we're gonna clip and cut
all of these screeching that Tim pulls
an MRA or something ever know I'm I'm a
legit
pretty minded equality and you know kind
of person and I respect individuals but
we got to be real man you're not gonna
see save like Muggsy Bogues
five-foot-three dude in the NBA right
it's rare it's a rare thing and it's not
because they're high test it's because
to win you got to be told yeah and
that's true for so much other stuff for
incredibly good like he Bugsy was
awesome he was amazing dude he could 360
dunk he could jump his own body yeah I
don't know what he's up to now I mean
I'm not a big NBA person but I'm sure
there's a bunch of other people like
that too you know thanks for checking
out this segment from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show every Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. sometimes an
hour or two and we do have a full live
recorded version of the show that
includes a lot of comments and smaller
segments you probably don't see if you
want to check that out you can watch
live at 8 p.m. Monday through Friday or
become a member of this channel and for
five bucks a month you get full access
to all of the recorded podcasts every
day after the show we make them
available in the community section of
this YouTube channel so don't forget to
subscribe and stick around for more
segments and more shows Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all in the next show
you